do you get paraders that are too
arrogant well I would say sometimes when
we get the rookies in from college
there's a decru process that goes on
uhhuh some of his players comes out in
college he gets drafted um you know he's
the best player on the team in college
right and it's playing against a lot of
other bad players on other teams who are
you know freshman sof me he's just
better than everybody well you come in
the National Football League there's not
too many rookies that are better than
everybody there's very very few
um so they quickly have to learn that if
you do things the way you did them in
college you're not it's not going to
work here the other guys are faster than
you the other guys are stronger than you
the other guys have more experience than
you like you've got to find a way to do
things right to be successful and so
sometimes that process takes you know a
little while it could take a couple
weeks sometimes it could take a year of
bad bad results you know so there's a
there's a d recruiting you know and it's
kind of I'm sure it's same thing in
college on you know some of the high
school kids big high school recruits
some of them work out some of them don't
and part of it's because they think
they're already just better than
everybody else but they're not not at
the next
level